una amplia concentración contra la
reforma electoral la respaldada por el
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador miles de opositores al
mandatario salieron a las calles de la
capital mexicana y de otras ciudades del
país para denunciar las posibles
enmiendas a la comisión electoral el INE
sus críticos dicen que temen que el jefe
de estado concentre todo el poder en sus
manos porque estamos en contra de la
propuesta de reforma electoral que está
proponiendo el partido Morena que quiere
destrozar a la democracia mexicana para
llevarnos a lugares como Venezuela y
Cuba entre los manifestantes se
encontraban el ex presidente de derecha
Vicente Fox así como grandes figuras
empresariales del país el INE no se toca
y aquí estamos cientos de miles de
jóvenes que vamos a dar la batalla por
este instituto que muchas vidas costó a
muchas personas en el país y que Oh
claro que es perceptible y que claro que
lo podemos mejorar pero no con su
reforma autoritaria que nos quiere
quitar a un órgano autónomo el congreso
comenzó la semana pasada a discutir el
plan presentado en abrir por López
Obrador quien durante mucho tiempo ha
criticado a las autoridades electorales
del país acusando las de haber
contribuido a sus derrotas cuando se
presentó a las elecciones presidenciales
de 2006 y 2012 según el mandatario la
reforma permitiría a los ciudadanos
elegir a las autoridades electorales y
reducir la influencia de los intereses
económicos en la política agregó que
reduciría la financiación de los
partidos políticos y limitaría el tiempo
de publicidad todavía muy popular en
México López Obrador fue elegido en 2018
para un único mandato de 6 años que
terminará en 2024
[Aplausos]